Fff... je suis crevé
Mille merci pour hier soir
Vous nous avez fait le meilleur accueil possible.
Le lancement n'était pas parfait, y a eu pas mal
de problèmes vous nous avez fait énormément
de retour et d'ailleurs merci, parce que ça nous aide à avancer et à évoluer.
Le premier gros problème c'était le son, c'était
un peu la merde apparemment sur le live.
Le deuxième problème c'est que ça faisait un peu trop télé
il y a des gens qui ont eu un ressenti, qui ont eu l'impression
de voir une émission de télé et je comprends tout à fait
Il y a eu un pique à plus de 140 000 viewers
Du coup on avait une pression de malade
et effectivement on s'est tous tenu un petit peu
en retrait, on osait pas trop faire les choses à l'arrache
comme on adore les faire
Mais vous inquiétez pas, c'était la toute première émission
Donc tous les prochains Primes ce sera beaucoup plus fluide, beaucoup plus d'improvisations
Ce qui impliquera aussi beaucoup plus de galère
Mais c'est pas grave c'est ça qu'on aime on est sur internet
Et le troisième reproche que vous avez fait c'était qu'on a pas parlé de la ...
De la programmation ni des Streamers
j'ai pas présenté les Streamers et j'ai pas présenté le programme
Alors c'était prévu mais en début de prime
Et c'est complètement con de commencer le Prime avec ça
enfin je trouve
du coup je l'ai zappé et mais j'aurai du effectivement à la fin
revenir la-dessus et en parler
Et je suis désolé pour ceux qui attendaient ça
et du coup on était un peu déçu
MAIS du coup on va faire une émission
là dans 40 minutes
Pour présenter en détail les Streamers et le programme
et cette émission sera en rediffusion sur la chaîne You Tube "Le Stream"
le lien est dans la description n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
Comme ça vous pourrez être au courant de vraiment qu'est-ce qui va y avoir sur le Stream
et vous décidez de si vous décidez et ...
Pff... J'arrive plus à parler.
comme ça vous allez pouvoir vous projetez et savoir si des émissions sont susceptible de vous intéressez ou non
Ah !  Quatrièmement aussi mais sa je pense c'est plus les gens qui sont déjà habituées au stream ils voulaient plus de jeux vidéos
Mais le Prime c'est une émission où le principe c'est de pas faire de jeux vidéo ou très peu
La pour la première on a fait que la Nintendo Switch
mais faut se dire que c'est juste une émission d'une heure et quelque le Mercredi
mais les six jours qui suivent il y a un milliard d'émissions où c'est du jeu vidéo.
Donc ne vous en faites pas pour ça vous allez voir Gotaga et Micka mettre des gros headshot et carry des games sur H1Z1 ou Overwatch y a pas de soucis pour ça.
Et cinquièmement bah le site qui est pas mal buggé  ya plein de truc à optimiser
ne serait-ce qu'au niveau des succès quand tu regardes deux heures d'un stream bein,  ça te compte que vingt minutes.
Fin on dirait que c'est Pokémon Go tu sais avec les pas ... Pour les œufs !!
Non ?  Ok...
Généralement dans la vie j'ai peur de  me lancer dans des gros projets
parce que ça me sort de ma zone de confort et j'ai peur de sortir de ma zone de confort un peu comme tout le monde.
Mais là je me suis dit ça vaut le coup y a plein de potes dans le truc, ils me font tous confiance je leur fais tous confiance y a aucune raison pour que ça foire.
Merci !!
Je vous ai pas assez remercié pendant le Prime parce qu'on était vraiment sous pression dans le truc et tout
Fiou.. Qu'est-ce que ça fait du bien de.. Allez, on a fait la première émission. Mainant (Maintenant) le truc est lancé
Et moi je vais au Japon
Eh oui! Je suis explosé, j'ai plus que besoin de vacances
Et je vais partir cette année au Japon avec mon frère et avec mon père
Entre couille, entre Hauchard!
Quand j'étais allé au Japon l'année dernière, je me suis dis il faut que j'amène mon père et mon frère ici
ils vont absolument adorer. ça va les détendre, ça va leurs faire du bien.
Et cette année du coup, je leur offre ce voyage parce qu'on a tous un peu besoin de se ressourcer et de vivre des trucs en famille
Moi j'ai jamais étais très famille et... Ouais, quand je faisais des voyages, je les subissais, quand je voyais ma famille, je le subissais..
Alors que là, ça part d'une volonté générale de partir en famille et s'amuser en famille et créer des souvenirs trop cool.
Et je trouve ça important.
C'était le petit moment émotion. ça vous as plu ?
Moi oui.
Je pars donc demain (le 11/03/2017) au JAPON! Mais pas de panique je vous ai fait des vidéos d'avance. Je ne vous en ai pas fait énormément,
parce que si j'en fait de trop, bah y en a certaines elles vont puer la m****
Alors que là je trouve, elles sont toutes un peu cool. Vous verrez, je vous fais la surprise.
Eh bah, voilà les amis je voulais juste vous faire un petit message avant de m'envoler au Japon et on se retrouve très bientôt dans un VLOG La semaine prochaine.
Et puis.....
Je m'envais.... Je vais faire de ce pas ma valise.
Je cherche des objets, une valise pour faire un mime. Genre "je fais ma valise" mais c'est de la m****. C'est de la m****
À très bientôoooooooooot........
(Malaise/20)
Heyy, c'est cool le JAPON